tiens mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça ce
serait pas jumbo qui a percé un s'achète
pas dans l'espoir d'en manger bon
certainement pas certainement pas non je
te paie une grosse dispute aujourd'hui
j'ai envie d'être achetés de faire tout
les mêmes conneries kadjo abo fait pour
ce tailleur jupe qui existe qui
s'appelle 4 latéral dommage et c'est
partir un jour l'objectif mode voilà on
va greffer des canapés volet de la
bouffe apprend à jouer comme je sais
déjà je vois du monde tous les jours
faire ça tape des objets pour qu'il
tombe par terre way 360 petit bisou à
maman sur le tableau un opus car en
pacha jolie alors là désolé mais jumbo
est bien plus beaux bras à ça fait
tellement du bien [ __ ] mais jusqu'où
pourquoi il fait ça en fait assez bon de
faire tomber des têtes un [ __ ] de
chat vous avez bien décrire fait une
connerie alors je vais pas pris en
flagrant délit puisqu'il est trop fourbe
mais en attendant monsieur essayez de
manger des coquillettes pas cuites
jobs dans la boîte pour continuer
regardez comme il est mignon ceux qui
t'ont kull allait la suite plus tard je
greffer des rideaux ou il ya dans les
poubelles réveiller mon maître à 7h du
mat pour lui demander à manger
c'est humain perron mais on n'a rien
fait [ __ ] nourriront de karez pourquoi
tu veux faire payer quoi ag du tout je
dois faire tomber plein de trucs
auxquels ce parti alors la manga alors
là mon gars tu sais pas par qui on a été
entraînée nous par le pire de tous les
chats de belmokhtar taux à 3 heures du
mat et qui te fait un peu flipper qu'en
fait c'est pas un chat c'est un
psychopathe qui vient de rentrer chez
toi pour te tuer je fais le bruit aux
voix la [ __ ] locale qui détachent des
plafonds
oh la vache j'ai eu peur oh là là je
pensais que c'était autre chose au sa
buse abonnez vous
il ya 260 objets à faire tomber mais mon
gars bla bla bla
les cahiers les feuilles des robots ils
disaient ils ces mesures je m'appelle
djobo je fais longtemps tous vues ne
vais souvent avec booba je passe ma prix
opus et la musique a plus qu'à voir du
monde quoi on pourrait mettre ça se
serait même pas plus kawaï
tout doit disparaître [ __ ] even ces
coins des bandes haven le maouloud
karachi djouri est pleine ou trop toi je
veux juste faire des caresses au pont
l'abbé h
hop là bas one on est trop puissant à
tanger un power up japon europe ces eaux
je suis super vite ta part qu'on nous
poussait à contrôler un bordel des
clochettes sous cocaïne [ __ ] mais ça
ça ne disent pas rien j'aime pas les
cahiers clairefontaine je les shoots
comme ça mais déjà la moitié du temps
avec toi fait c'est dur d'être un chat
aux eaux la télé [ __ ] alors là el
jamoussi fait ça mon gars belle brassée
grosyeux le fracas larrouy hockey est ce
qu a pris à la réaction du maître
cohérente chez lui complique bonus plus
au 29 mai à mon grand rond va jouer à ce
à quoi tu t'amuses a joué tous les jours
dans la vraie vie je raye des trucs et
15 des objets leur ligue des mdr c'est
trop drôle genou sur le clavier et je
fais tomber tous les objets de du bureau
de l'udc à quoi faut car ces 288 mille
dollars d'objets et pour ça on a onze
minutes mais attend à bientôt sa
démission et dureront une heure quoi ça
suffit bordel c'est qu'on n'a pas de lui
mais quand même
oui quand même alors là je vais tomber
délivrer les feuilles a4 on est dur à
500 $ - ja j'ai pas le gameplay on
aimait la vie elle coûte très cher et
j'ai fait tomber une épée comme les
chevaliers et 20 des voix c'est [ __ ]
j'ai à la broche et fait de mal mais
j'avoue que c'est trop chou regardez
comme on s'amuse dans un dojo un chat à
l'esha dégage touche aaa
oh là là j'ai débloqué un nouveau chat
rufus attend le mec s'est donnée pour
faire son jeu quand même quoi ce qui
rend c'est que le mec a créé le jeu
c'est comme moi et l'argent qui fait
plein de caudry ce que lui il a craqué
son style il s'est dit je vais je vais
consacrer six mois navy a développé un
jeu dans lequel tu casse tout en tant
que cha ses explications un peu longue
pour une chute un peu moyenne mais moi
plus je suis un maniaque je veux plus
qui rien sur la table s'il reste un peu
d'objets ça compte pas quoi jusqu'à
avoir une magnifique table voilà avec
rien dessus mondial ça ça doit coûter
une aux blindes un véritable squelette
de t-rex mais non mais mon gars gardez
rien et les dollars a dégagé dégagé
voilà complètement gardait un char
parfait 280 objet il ya des chiites au
mouillage wee aa non mais là c'est trop
triste mais dans un dortoir d'enfants et
le chien ça cache tous ces palais qui
verse pas les heures sup à tout nettoyer
la boue avant je parle déjà d'heures sup
quoi ou donné que j'ai carrément des
enfants qui travaillent pour moi oui je
vais en plus voilà s'est achevée une
vidéo mais en fait je veux juste qu'il
fait tout défoncer dans ce jeu ah non le
petit trou on aurait dû le film et ça on
aurait dû filmer le chat qui tombe dans
le trou on aurait fait huit millions de
vu si un jour je rentre et que je vois
que jumbo a fait ça mais qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que je peux faire ça à la
ruelle est ce que je dois faire c'est le
pire c'est le pire la verrerie [ __ ] je
le donnerai jeu à choir un giveaway y de
mon chat soit 6 max c'est con mais c'est
la fois à ok c'est la vitesse à laquelle
je frappe le chat super ça donne quoi
[Musique]
voilà j'ai mis un bordel à aller je vais
en salle tout rien dans la caisse je
ratais ckoi niveau d'après 500 objets
non mais non mais là on a une vie quand
même non mais non mais faut dire ce qui
est les gens veulent détruire plein
d'objets pendant tout ce média est catho
et richters cateau et acheteurs ils ont
été isolés étaient des [ __ ] ils sont
méchants en plus c'est ce point que la
colonne ça c'est très vicieux ça comme
acte un event un boost gratuit est
apparu les dommages et désiré et votre
arbuste payant est apparue seigneur tu
vas au boost elle a demandé pays cathare
ou quoi voilà je pense d'ailleurs
bizarre alors ce qui est bien c'est que
le gameplay est riche et très varié
vraiment à aucun vente et impression de
faire la même chose depuis une heure
c'est un vrai plaisir à jouer
et voilà c'est la fin nous avons gagné
et là il va me dire faire tomber mille
objets sas autre nom mais là c'est beau
le franchement je pense j'ai compris le
but du joueur c'était très sympa très
doux très soyeux comme les poils de nez
d'un chat
[Musique]
débat avec le masque de batman la mode
c'est déjà un poids de 7 2 sur 4 ha
terrain des maîtres chiens ça vous a
plus c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à mes
rêves de haut comme d'habitude je sens
que ça a plu à jumbo
mais savoir garder un certain talent
attendant une prochaine vidéo voilà j'ai
définitivement lâché toute la haine que
j'avais envers les bêtises que jumbo
fait on s'est retrouvé dans une
prochaine vidéo merci d'avoir regardé
tout le monde pis
[Musique]